let's do one more element of the Tucker
Carlson Revelations from the text
messages and then we'll move on to other
text message revelations in a private
text reports Media Matters Tucker
Carlson called Trump skipping the Biden
inauguration destructive on his show he
didn't mention that and pretended that
coverage of trump skipping the
inauguration was unhinged this is
another way
in which Tucker Carlson was playing a
character wherein the things he said to
his audience were completely different
from the things he said privately Media
Matters reports New Revelations from a
recent court filing in the Dominion
voting system's defamation suit revealed
Tucker Carlson's true opinion about
Trump not going to the Biden
inauguration so destructive and we have
the text messages here
um Tucker is told by an unknown person
maybe you already knew but Gates told me
Trump isn't going to the inauguration
and Tucker says I'd heard that about the
inauguration hard to believe so
destructive that's the right analysis
this tells us this is worse than Tucker
being delusional I believe this is
Tucker having the same opinion I have
and you have which is wow part of the
peaceful transition of power in the
United States is that the outgoing
president goes to the inauguration of
the incoming president the totally
standard uncontroversial View
Tucker doesn't actually think it's a
good thing for Trump to skip the
inauguration he shares my view he shares
what I'm sure is your view
but that's not what he said on the air
and if we actually go to the types of
things that Tucker did say on the air
about the inauguration they included
making fun of Jim Acosta for wearing a
mask and not mentioning ever by the way
it's not good that Trump is skipping
this it's bad for the country here's
just one example of Tucker's coverage of
that inauguration of losing their job
Jim Acosta CNN lost his job you may not
have read that he's no longer going to
be there chief White House correspondent
he's still oppressed though today Jim
Acosta is celebrated the ouster of a
dictator fascist so bad that Jim Acosta
got a book deal out of criticizing him
those Horrors are behind us now thank
God Jim Acosta is celebrating the
dictator is gone
so he Anderson this is looking like uh
you know a president or a foreign head
of state leaving Washington uh and you
know in a way uh because the president
is uh defying these traditions of not
being a part of the inauguration of
President Joe Biden uh he's almost
leaving town like a uh an autocrat uh
Alice did from Power heading off into
exile
it's just hilarious that someone who is
literally wearing a black mask on
cameras calling someone else a fascist
why are you wearing a mask you're not
going to get coveted outside at a live
shot okay so Tucker's actual belief we
now know was you know what Jim Acosta is
right it is a really bad thing that
Trump isn't going to this inauguration
but what he said instead was why is Jim
Acosta wearing a mask Outdoors
he is playing a character and it's a
disgusting character and it's a
profitable character but privately he
thought Trump should go to the
inauguration and he hates Trump
passionately these are the people
that Maga listens to will they keep
listening now that these Revelations
have come out I don't know let me know
depends on whether they even hear about
it one of our sponsors is zipix nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zippix toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpicks.com today save 10 with
the code pacman10 at checkout just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below